hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter two of
his essay on Liberty which is arguing
for why we ought to not impose
restrictions on free speech or as he
calls an expression of opinion including
publication mill is going to be making
an argument that's not appealing
primarily to rights but rather to
utility he is a utilitarian and so the
usefulness or the you might say
preponderance of positive benefits over
negative harms generated by doing
certain things
that's what's foremost in his mind and
he provides a number of different
supporting arguments for this and one of
the most interesting ones has to do with
what we can call and what he calls
overcoming one-sidedness one-sidedness
of what one-sidedness of truth meaning
and this is a common term in the 19th
century in the early 20th century
particularly in philosophy meaning
elimination of a sort of myopic you
might say blinkered or blind 'red way of
looking at things that is able to take
in
you account the totality or at least as
much as we can get a bit of truth about
a manner and there's a lot of things
before we look at Mills examples there's
a lot of things in which we get just a
partial viewpoint on things and we could
have a better one I'll give you a prime
example right now you're getting my take
on John Stuart Mill's work which is a
take on a particular topic so you've
already got an interpretation of an
interpretation and we might bring other
partners into the conversation in the
way that mill is actually suggesting
here in order to overcome that
one-sidedness and have the opposite
which would be many sidedness or a
fullness of perspective so Mill points
out early on in this section he says
that one of the principal causes which
makes diversity of opinion advantageous
and will continue to do so until mankind
shall have entered a stage of
intellectual advancement which at
present seems at an incalculable
distance meaning that there could be a
time eventually where we've figured it
all out and we don't need multiple
points of view but we're nowhere near
that right now and clearly in the
present day horn nope we're in here that
150 years after mill so he says we've
considered only two possibilities up
until now that the received opinion may
be false the received opinion is sort of
the majority view and some other opinion
consequently true right some minority
opinion or that the received opinion
being true a conflict with the opposite
error is essential to a clear
apprehension and a deep feeling of its
truth so these are these are different
possibilities right but there's another
third possibility what if the received
opinion the the majority view what we
might call the common sense view what if
it's partly true but partly false what
if it's missing something what if the
way in which it's framed is leaving
something out
or inducing people to look at some
things in the wrong way so he says
there's a commoner case than either of
these when the conflicting doctrines
instead of being one true and the other
false share the truth between them what
does it mean to share the truth between
them so just to get over any sort of
miss readings of this it doesn't mean
that they agree upon a common truth it
means that there's some truth over here
on one side and then there's another
portion of truth over here on the other
side and when you put them together then
you get more truth overall whereas if
you insist on one side or the other side
exclusively you're missing out on
something because you have deprived
yourself of the opportunity of
considering and and apprehending the
truth that's available on the other side
so he says that in these cases the
non-conforming opinion is needed to
supply the remainder of the truth of
which the received doctrine embodies
only a part and then he goes on and
gives you no nice truism here popular
opinions on subjects not palpable to
sense are often true but seldom or never
the whole truth they are part of the
truth sometimes a greater sometimes a
smaller part but exaggerated distorted
and is joined from from the truths by
which they ought to be accompanied and
limited and you know we could think of
all sorts of contemporary examples of
this we you know we're subject to all
sorts of cognitive biases so we pay more
attention to the things that already fit
in with our general way of looking at
things
and we tend to ignore downplay or
sometimes even just totally reject
things that don't fit in with that as
well and by doing so by sticking with
that that one opinion we are embracing a
one-sided viewpoint on truth so the
non-conforming opinion is going to be
important here he says heretical
opinions are generally some of these
suppressed and neglected truths
putting the bottoms which kept them down
and either seeking reconciliation with
the truth contained in the common
opinion or fronting it as enemies and
setting themselves up with similar
exclusiveness as the whole truth and
this is quite common
by the way Mill is not saying that
there's anything inherently better about
non-conforming or heretical opinions
he's not romanticizing the lonely genius
who is you know in touch with things
that we're missing out on no he's just
being very realistic about this in any
given case odds are that the truth is
something complex and it's shared across
a number of different perspectives
another point that he makes very
interesting a little bit later on just
you know a few sentences down he has to
do with progress and you know that mill
is a big advocate of progress and he
often tends to talk about the forces of
order or conservativism as if they are
in some way you know backwards and and
not particularly in touch with the truth
you know but here he says in revolutions
of opinion one part of the truth usually
sets well another rises even progress
which ought to super add for the most
part only substitutes one partial and
incomplete truth for another what does
he mean by super adds there so the idea
would be something like the the the
vision or the ideology that we have of
the way that the sciences work right not
only do we have the whole you know
scientific method thing but then there's
this idea we're gradually expanding our
universe of what we know from all these
things that we can take for granted it
doesn't really work that way
you know if you ask people engaged in
some sort of technical process or any
sort of you know academic discipline
very often they will tell you if they're
being honest well you know I studied
this and that back in college but we
kind of passed over quickly and I've
forgotten all that I don't
no I just sort of take it for granted
that all of these things are true and
what's what's happened is the stuff
that's in front of them is what they
they know and progress itself often
works that way we've made a lot of
progress in the time since mill and
there have been some truths that have
been lost in the process some
perspectives you might think for example
of the in anglo-american philosophy
obviously not in other areas of
philosophy or they never did forget this
of the famous revival or Renaissance of
virtue ethics where suddenly analytic
philosophers largely analytic
philosophers realized that they left
something out of moral philosophy and
focusing exclusively on egoism and
konchem ISM and other de forms of de
ontology and utilitarianism we left out
virtue ethics well there were some
truths that had been left out and then
we have authors like say Alistair
MacIntyre you know in from the 80s on
wearing boots and the notion of
character traits there's also this whole
issue of traditions and which are
healthy in which are you know moribund
and and you know he devoted himself to
that sort of thing that would be
bringing back something that had been a
truth that had been lost in the process
and then you know you get some virtue
ethics who at the cysts who just super
add or some substitute rather than then
super adding which would go against
would say again MacIntyre suggests
interestingly enough Mill is one of the
authors who MacIntyre thinks virtue
ethics absolutely must take seriously
and bring in which would be a process of
super adding rather than merely
substituting so there that's a nice
example there but all progress tends to
work this way he says he says that
improvement consists chiefly and this
the new fragment of truth is more wanted
more adapted to the needs of the time
than that which it displaces so we often
lose
in the process now he goes on and he
talks about how one-sided assertive of
partially true but non-conforming
doctrines are useful or helpful to us
how is that actually the case well you
know they're providing us with something
that were otherwise going to be missing
he says there are things that we
otherwise would have overlooked and we
won't overlook them if somebody is
bringing them to our attention now
there's a little bit of optimism there
that will we'll take into account what
other people have to say without
immediately dismissing them he's got
some really interesting examples here
and one of them is worth fleshing out in
much greater detail which I'll do
elsewhere but we'll at least mention it
so these examples what are they have how
one-sidedness one-sidedness of people
who almost seem like cranks themselves
like in the case of root so turned out
to be very important so let's look at
the case of Rousseau first he says in
the 18th century when nearly all the
instructed and all of the uninstructed
led by them were lost an admiration of
what is called civilization
and of the marvels of modern science
literature and philosophy greatly
overrating the amount of unlike Ness
between the men of modern times and
those of ancient times when they
indulged the belief that the whole of
the difference was in their own favor
that that they now understood things
rightly with what a salutary shock did
the paradoxes of Rousseau explode like
bombshells in the midst dislocating the
compact mass of one-sided opinion and
forcing its elements to recombine in a
better form and with additional
ingredients now this is very nice
rhetoric there and Mills part what is he
talking about most of the the
intelligentsia and naturals in
philosophy across the board in the 18th
century we're saying things are getting
better and better I mean we still have
absolute you know despot and there's all
these problems going on but we can
probably fix these
and civilization consists in
enlightenment in in moving forward with
these sorts of things and Rousseau comes
along and says civilization while it
does in fact improve us in certain ways
also makes us able to do more bad things
and it has an inherently corrupting
effect upon us he says this in a lot of
different ways his various discourse is
the social contract you know his his
work Emil right all these sorts of
things that he's bringing forward and
also the way that he's engaging with the
the intelligentsia of his time through
letters and actions and all of that sort
of stuff and we're so is seen as being
and what we nowadays call an outlier or
you know a maverick somebody who's on
the the outside of things as a matter of
fact he and Voltaire who also embodies
the time don't fit in together very well
but Rousseau turns out to be quite
important in pointing out where
civilization is not living up to its
great promises and well Rousseau himself
this is what Mill thinks is not entirely
right as a matter of fact he's probably
not even half right if we take his works
as a totality he certainly is putting
important things on the table which then
the other authors can say oh yeah you
know okay maybe we were a little bit
hasty maybe we were a little bit
one-sided in our approach to things so
Rousseau is a great example another
prime example political life now Mill is
framing this and rather diametric terms
but we could see this in terms of
multiple party systems as well so he
says in politics it's almost a
commonplace that you need two parties to
have healthy political life a party of
progress and reform and a party of order
and stability and he says until the one
or the other shell is so enlarged its
mental grasp as to be a part of the
party equally of order and progress he
says each of these modes of thinking
derives
utility from the deficiencies of the
other but it's in great measure the
opposition of the other that keeps each
within the limits of reason and sanity
so I you know and this is questionable
whether it really works this way in
crisis situations or in times of
incredible factional ization but you do
have to admit that there's something
there at least this is partially true
right that in many cases the two parties
provide policies proposals focuses ideas
that contribute to the whole and each of
them usually is unwilling to listen to
the other about how great their ideas
are but they're occasionally prone to do
that so for a great example of that
right now here in the United States is
prison reform for a long time it's it's
been the case that on the left there was
a great interest in prison reform we
have you know a lot of troubles in our
entire penal system which isn't even
really a system but rather a patchwork
of systems and conservatives were much
more of the law and order lock em up
throw away the key
retributive mentality and then we had
the sort of center left was not that
interested in these issues except for
you know occasionally some people or
some some portions of the party would be
helpful with that and eventually we've
come to the realization more or less
across the spectrum at least when it
comes to political agents that what
we've got going on right now is a
failure an utter failure it's it's
horrific and its effects there there's
very little oversight of jails and
prisons across the nation correctional
officers as many of whom are you know
very poorly paid and in difficult
situations themselves are getting away
with all sorts of things that they
shouldn't be the conditions in prisons
are inhumane we really need to have an
emphasis on prison education that we
used to have but retributive measures
removed or austerity measures in some
cases as well there's a consensus now
among
conservatives and liberals that this
ought to change which is one reason why
I'm teaching in prisons again on the
second chance Pell program so that's an
example of what mill is talking about
here with with political parties they
they each put different things on the
table and they work out some sort of
deal now a third example that he brings
up and I'm not going to talk too much
about this because there's so much
discussion that we can put it into a
separate talk Christian morality and and
he says you know we got to figure out
what Christian morality actually means
but let's say we actually do understand
what it is and it is some sort of system
so he says that the Christian system is
no exception to the rule that in an
imperfect state of the human mind the
interest of truth require a diversity of
opinions and where would it get that
from he says other ethics then any which
can be evolved from exclusively
Christian sources must exist side by
side with Christian ethics to produce
the moral regeneration of mankind so you
would want secular ethics you would want
things that perhaps came out of
Christian ethics and then where
secularized things that can be taught as
not simply being Christian ethics things
that perhaps were pre-christian you
would want to at least bring those to
the table actually if you look at the
history of Christianity and Christian
ethics Mill is a little bit you know
deforming the way things actually took
place here each facts about the first
five centuries there is an incredible
amount of taking in other ideas from
non-christian sources and adapting them
within the fabric or framework of what
we can call Christian ethics but when
people are saying like us if it's not in
the Bible then we don't practice it well
you need something else to overcome that
one-sidedness and in places where
something that we call Christian ethics
would be the dominant morality then you
need some other perspectives to supply
the missing truth so this is this is you
know three examples here of how this
would actually
can practice this overcoming
one-sidedness it's only going to take
place according to mill if we do in fact
allow a diversity of opinions to be
expressed
so that perspectives can be confronted
with alternate or rival perspectives and
then the missing parts can be filled in
and we can arrive and if not a perfect
and comprehensive perspective that
encompasses all truth which is a little
bit unrealistic Mill would say at this
stage we can at least make some progress
in that direction
you